at that time I was on the front page of
The Wall Street Journal back in the day
say how have you rock like a totally
different person no [ __ ] come from the
outside a little bit for people okay you
can build franchises when you build
franchises you sell [ __ ]
one thing I want to make sure all of you
know is that we I'm gonna throw a lot of
things like this and I want to like
support them let's make sure everybody
knows like that's important like we want
to build up the franchise we want to
tell people on the floor like telling
people like did you get the email this
morning like the more we can build up
things the more we can have that that's
how you get marketing success so just
keep that in the back of your mind gonna
go for it all now it's a lot man
you know what I'll talk to you more
about what I know I'll see you guys a
little bit so I won't oh boy love you
love it
brain this is what we have to focus on
why you to start like spending real time
looking at this put like come and do a
competitor offer right now with free
shipping reduced price for two bucks
less than decoy
hey one another via you well yeah
yeah looking good say it say hello
everybody
all right
I want to tape sing until we get there
what's that hey Kim how are you cool
let's stop fool around we only got a few
minutes anything obviously Jo you gave
me some stuff for my meeting with London
went really well looks like there's a
opportunity for the UK market one thing
I want all of you to hear is I believe
the most dysfunctional thing that I've
seen in business since I've started
vaynermedia is how our brands handle
global and local markets I have no
interest in being a version of that with
London and as a local market for and
then New York being on the global
business so in general I think that's
going to start happening to us over the
next step decade and I think it's a
great opportunity for this team because
it's really more you guys than those
guys it's us as a group being the bigger
men and women and really supporting the
London office and then their efforts in
the UK market that it so I've said this
to Jo I'm saying I know not all of you
work on it but I think we're gonna start
getting more UK specific or Europe
specific business in 17 so that's on my
mind I'm excited about that we'll have
more conversations about that please
default into supporting them creatively
you know and physically as much as
possible and always being empathetic to
how much more important it is to them in
the beginning especially so keep that in
mind that's on my mind and then so
that's for me that's kind of my stuff
anything from you guys thanks for making
it course good if you just get in I got
just Lina from London Gerry can you see
red how are you good how are you good
you know we can't record this me yes but
I want to at least get this part because
I'm trying to get you in as many
dailyvees as possible all right dear
Rach have fun yep
and just just so everybody knows great
and the and just so everybody knows how
I view this cuz there's you know there's
a lot of things I'm passionate about
obviously you guys know me you'd be
stunned how much more I believe I'm
right about this than a lot of other
things that I may seem to be more
passionate about that's great and team
and everybody the punchline of all this
is it's a human-being thing right like
like the reason it doesn't work is
because the global person Samantha and
the local person Rick aren't letting it
work the reason it wouldn't work is
because Chris and Tim didn't let it work
like like this is just like it's just
human beings and so so cool and do that
but it's all interpretation and it's all
just human beings I'm very confident in
our ability internally to do our thing I
just want everybody to know how much I'm
keeping an eye on it and how much I'll
be judging if we even have a hiccup you
know what I mean I want you guys to make
a four or five page deck on why creative
and paid working together matters with
real detail and creative make a six page
deck this is important deck
I want this fast and and you've got it
and you've got a deck
I said six-page Dec and honestly you've
now set a new standard for speed up
which I want stuff so be prepared to
deliver on that you better just start
making decks on spec um all right I got
to run I love you guys talk to you soon
all right okay
so what's cooking hi how are you good
hey how are you
Wine Library baby old stomping grounds
it's the best feeling to be here like
riding your bike right like riding a
[ __ ] bike why do you always hit
the curse
hello idea and there's good stuff in
there too
I don't give a [ __ ] okay I'm good idea I
mean here's what acts
where's-where's I let's do it right now
go to I'm gonna I'm gonna talk you
through this where the orders coming in
basically every [ __ ] order show me
the last order that just came in the
form you all five of you about to call a
human being but I but here's the real
interesting thing and while I've got all
of you
Liz George trip I don't think every one
of them has to be a sales call I think
Liz like so what's the Lea sorter I want
you to email him and I want you to tell
him to when he when he opens the bellow
to make sure it breathes for multiple
hours that's it all right Liz your turn
here yeah let's go actually just let's
actually pick back out cuz I want to
know something great I want you to
basically vom great I basically want you
to email and call them with something
now let's debate it let's look at their
account what else do they know something
bought
um you don't call her call her be like
you're looking at the account appreciate
the order you just place for the
Sancerre see that you love it
if you ever need any San Siro
recommendations or so via Blanc
recommendations or if you ever want me
to notify you when we get really
intriguing some of the monks that we're
not gonna promote on the email let me
know just like us thank you got it
call be like super excited that yeah I'm
super excited for you to let me know how
what I love for you to let me know what
you think once you try it and really
appreciate it and the store anything I
can ever do for you you've got my email
and I got it doing a love it ah God love
selling stuff
start zoning in and being creative on
one-to-one sale like if you can start
looking at customers one by one that's
the zone I let when I send you [ __ ]
unsocial I love for you to recommend
enough page four to page 10 that's like
the beefy spot
be very now you may not have a
recommendation that fits what you need
to but be very educated on what's
sitting on page four to ten let's look
at it let's just keep jamming this is
fun how much I meant lemons
yeah everybody sign it is did you get
him sign in like is he getting at okay
cool
there's this has it this George habit
sign in that way hey like what I mean we
had labels and reviews on every product
within 12 hours like this is like we're
probably sitting with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] Malbec for [ __ ] a month and
we have nine cases of it and it just it
has no prayer because as if it's not
reviewed here in a labeled means it has
no shelf talker so
that's it that's what I'm really
passionate about like this whole world
it also really helps if you're grounded
in the first ten pages to like when
you're doing recommendations because
there's gonna be more knowledgeable
about the inventory you know what I mean
done I'll get it done right now sorry
sorry let's see yeah
no not for me only because I love the
game like I you know I could be far more
successful financially if I didn't love
the game and I love money
most of my behaviors about the game I'm
poor I'm creating scenarios that make me
work 16 hours a day you know I could
probably work 10 and make twice the
amount of money that's done by the way
not probably I'm telling you right now I
can work ten hours a day and make 50 to
100 percent more money if I changed my
behavior it's just not what makes me
happy
I love the game I love the game like you
would not believe I loved the game when
I was making $75,000 a year and I was
happy as a clam I'm shy
the money is unbelievably not
interesting meaning I'm thrilled I'll
take it
I'm a winner that I needed to buy the
Jets and all that good jazz but that is
not my hardwiring that's a that's a
byproduct of Who I am
and by the way by the way I think that's
actually much more common than people
realize you know what I mean like
actually I do think that's the purest
form entrepreneur I think that you know
I'm so lucky like I'll tell you right
now this is not no hesitation I don't
need to make more right like if this was
it then you know I'm already
unbelievably blessed you know
like I can I don't need stuff like I
like flying private to save five hours
but I'm thrilled to fly coach middle
seat if I can't afford it it's not like
home and you know when you come from
very humble beginnings you pasted that
before you know it's not scary and by
the way I want to say something and I
want people to hear this because I don't
want to be I don't want tone lost I
think a lot of people here that say easy
for you you have it now right you know
and I'm empathetic to that and I
understand
I implore those people if they're
curious if there's truth to investigate
the people that knew me in 93 94 95 97
99 2001 2003 like I've always been this
happy it's always been this great
because I get to play the game you know
see ya good day wine library just
grindin while you're sleeping
how'd it go I'm amazing so so sick
I listen to every day but today I teared
up four people have already tweeted you
should run for president
am I getting emails like crazy it was
really good
did you like it what's up Facebook hats
Gary Vee
you